four live local now well minimum wage is
set to go up in just two days here in
nevada good afternoon and thank you so
much for joining us here at four i'm
christian casa and i'm vanessa murphy
starting july 1st the rate will be 9.50
an hour for employees who are offered
benefits and 10.50 for those who aren't
that's right our very own joe mueller is
live this afternoon on the strip with
how this may impact business owners joe
that's right this is going up 75 cents
on friday some business owners i talked
to say they already are paying more
because of the difficulties with hiring
during the pandemic others say they are
adjusting
i'm ok with it i mean more money so
sophia bscott works at crazy peta in the
southwest valley
i think it will help a lot because of
everything with covet she is like many
others who are happy to see minimum wage
go up the minimum wage has been changing
for the good and the better medi zarlul
is the owner he just opened this crazy
peta location on wednesday to attract
staff he has had to adjust the pay we've
been paying more
than the minimum wage we've been kind of
competitive with other industries
businesses all over have been impacted
by the pandemic including difficulties
hiring staff and that pushed many to
already increase rages all of our
kitchen staff already makes well over
minimum wage anyway so it's really just
going to affect our front of house staff
now it's going up 75 cents to 950 for
those with benefits and 10.50 without
it's definitely not helping my bottom
line john simmons owns firefly in the
southwest we bump the prices up a little
bit to make up for it and it's actually
a nice thing for people to get a little
little bump in their pay this is the
first bump in pay two more 75-cent
increases are set to take place in the
next few years in 2024 it will be 11 an
hour with benefits in 12 without it's
not
jumping up five dollars an hour in one
year but you know bumping up a puck or
50 cents a year you know keep up with
the
you know inflation too these days
those business owners say adjusting at
the 75 cents they won't really notice
much because they've already had to
increase wages because of the
difficulties hiring throughout the
pandemics so this adjustment won't be
impacting them too much reporting live
joe mulder live local now